hi my name is Timmy O'Neal and I'm a
climber and a kayaker and we're gonna be
talking about how to pull an all-nighter
[Music]
people wind up being stranded in the
backcountry overnight when they get lost
or they underestimate the amount of time
that it's going to take them to
accomplish their objective and they wind
up sleeping outside if you find yourself
in an all nighter situation immediately
understanding where you are geologically
and topographically will be important
for your comfort and safety in reference
to features that you want to be looking
for finding an area that is going to be
protected from the wind finding water
could be something that is quite
important depending upon when you ran
out one of the things is retaining your
body heat you want to have a barrier
between your body and the ground one of
the techniques that we use in climbing
is to take the rope and coil it on to
the ground creating a mat you shiver
through the night moving uncomfortably
back and forth foot to foot and maybe
you fall asleep for just a moment and
then you wake back up and you realize
it's still dark and it's gonna be a
while longer then you look over at your
partner and you realize that they're
made of body heat right now this
represents an opportunity for the Alpine
spoon
this is snuggling without any romantic
inclination this is simply taking one's
body and applying it to another body the
longer that you remain still the colder
your body will become the alternatives
would be to stand up and run in place do
jumping jacks
practice isometric exercises where you
fire your muscles essentially what
you'll be doing is rocking back and
forth desperately hoping for the Sun to
rise
so you've made it through the night now
what you want to do is compose yourself
make sure that you gather all your
belongings and slowly make your way down
to the trailhead
[Music]
[Music]